neige et températures en baisse ont
paralysé les routes ce week end mais pas
le réseau de transport d'électricité en
relation permanente avec météo france
les exploitants du réseau a juste de
façon continue le besoins en
consommation
ici dans les locaux du rte à montigny le
bretonneux
les équipes restent sereines nous avons
également actuellement une situation
favorable avec un réseau qui est
globalement très disponible donc une
situation qui nous permet d'affronter
une vague de froid avec un bon espoir et
puis grandes chances que ça se passe
bien le réseau achemine l'énergie depuis
les centrales jusqu'au point de
consommation à savoir les foyers les
bâtiments publics et les entreprises
actuellement la consommation
d'électricité ici en rouge reste en deçà
des prévisions en bleu on a connu des
niveaux de consommation beaucoup plus
élevé l'hiver dernier au mois de février
où la vague de froid était plus
rigoureuse ce qu on était dix degrés
sous les températures normales
saisonnières
on actuellement à peu près 5 degrés sous
les températures normales saisonnières
donc les froids qu'on subit actuellement
sont moins virulents 23 1300 mégawatts
consommés l'an dernier au plus fort de
la vague de froid
à l'heure actuelle la consommation n'a
pas encore atteint les 23 1000 mégawatts
de plus la neige sur les toits isole les
maisons il n'entraîne pas de pete de
chauffage mais le manque de luminosité
due à une forte couverture nuageuse
encouragea plus d'éclairage la situation
reste donc stable
pour autant les équipes du rte présente
24 heures sur 24 pour gérer 20% de la
demande électrique française entre l'île
de france et toute la normandie
demeurent vigilants météo france annonce
une chute des températures jusqu'à -4
degrés pour cette fin de semaine mais là
encore la situation semble déjà maîtrisé
les entreprises étant à l'arrêt les
samedis et dimanches
le réseau a alors davantage de marge de
manoeuvre pour chauffer les foyers